Caped crusaders and awesome avengers are everywhere
you look at the movies, and there's a great
selection of crowd-pleasing blockbusters that
take the format to new heights.
From '70s classics to modern-day epics, these
are the 30 best superhero movies ever made.
This 2010 film based on the comic series of
the same name isn't your typical superhero
story, and that's exactly what makes it so
great.
It's the story of a kid who really has no
business being a hero but does it anyway,
with bone-cracking, profane, with over-the-top
action.
Kick-Ass proved to be a breakout project for
Aaron Johnson and Chloë Grace Moretz, and
when veteran weirdo Nicolas Cage is involved,
how can you possibly go wrong?
Never mind.
Kick-Ass is great, though.
Chronicle gives the superhero genre the found
footage treatment, telling the story of three
teenagers who stumble upon a mysterious extraterrestrial
object that grants them seemingly limitless
superpowers.
Of course, being a teen is hard enough, but
being a teen with telekinesis?
Well, that's too much of a burden to bear,
and this superhero origin story quickly turns
evil.
A surprise hit, the movie resonated with critics
and fans alike.
Sure, there are moments when you'll wonder
why the cameras are still rolling as psychic
high school students battle it out in the
sky, but the movie is such a tense thrill
ride that you'll quickly forget any flaws
as the movie heads towards its inevitable
and horrific showdown.
Big Hero 6 is a loose adaptation of a quirky,
obscure Marvel comic, and was one of the best
films of 2014, animated, superhero, or otherwise.
It follows a kid whose brother is tragically
killed in a fire, and how he moves on from
that loss by making friends with his brother's
robot and the friends he left behind.
When they realize there must have been more
to the fire than it seemed, they suit up as
superheroes to get justice, but not even the
film's villain is as cut and dried as it might
appear.
The visuals are great, the tone is pitch perfect,
and there's even a Stan Lee cameo.
Liam Neeson has a special set of skills, and
that usually includes playing dudes you just
don't mess with.
"I see you when you're sleeping.
I know when you're awake."
But before he fought human traffickers, wolves,
and LEGO lawbreakers, he was Darkman.
This flick finds Neeson playing Peyton Westlake,
a scientist who becomes a scarred and reluctant
superhero.
Beneath the layers of monster makeup, Neeson
strikes the perfect balance of madness, righteous
anger, and pathos.
Notable for its bizarre rage sequences, clever
practical effects, and campy tone, this 1990
flick feels a mash-up of Batman, Evil Dead
II, and The Phantom of the Opera.
If you're tired of the usual Marvel and DC
fare, this film goes to weird and wacky places
most superhero movies would never dare.
Hellboy is a 2004 film which follows the titular
half-demon, memorably played by Ron Perlman,
as he helps humanity take on supernatural
threats.
Director Guillermo Del Toro's visual style
is perfectly suited to this story, which follows
Hellboy as he tries to figure out just exactly
what he is, while also battling all sorts
of baddies along the way.
The effects work is out of this world, and
the design of villains like the undead, clockwork
Kroenen is totally terrifying.
It takes a special kind of magic to get Hellboy
right, but del Toro and Perlman possess exactly
what it takes to give us a devilishly good
movie.
It's an absolute miracle this blood-soaked,
F-bomb drenched movie ever made it onto the
big screen, but aren't we all glad it did?
Deadpool lived in development hell for years,
and it took the leak of a concept reel to
finally jumpstart it.
The results are quick, filthy and fun, with
Ryan Reynolds born to play the part.
The Merc With A Mouth now holds the record
for the highest-grossing X-Men film and the
highest-grossing R-rated film in history.
A magnificent conflict between Sir Patrick
Stewart's Professor X and Sir Ian McKellan's
Magneto, 2003's X2: X-Men United is considered
by many to be the best of the original X-Men
trilogy, and it just couldn't be made today.
That energy and fierceness has dispersed from
popular imagination, replaced by the cynicism
of Deadpool and the grim pessimism of Logan.
Doing justice to its source material, the
1982 masterpiece God Loves, Man Kills, this
film is required viewing.
With 1989's Batman, director Tim Burton managed
to take a character best known for Adam West's
goofiness and turn him into a serious hero
for comic book fans.
With the franchise's staying power fading
fast in the late 1970s, it took more than
a decade to finally get a new adaptation mounted.
Many fans flew into an uproar over Michael
Keaton's casting in the title role, but one
look at the final film made all those worries
melt away.
Burton treated the canon seriously, and though
he didn't follow it note for note, he paid
tribute to it and built a living, breathing
version of Gotham City.
Combining the worlds of the original X-Men
trilogy with the X-Men prequel-sequel series
was a tall order, but Bryan Singer pulled
it off with his return to the franchise after
taking a break for a couple of films.
Days of Future Past managed to weave together
a story spanning decades, with two separate
casts, and still keep all the story tight
enough so even someone who's never seen an
X-Men film could follow along.
It also stealthily retconned out the atrocious
X-Men: The Last Stand, making all things right
within the cinematic X-universe.
Batman Returns is less about Batman than it
is about the creation of Catwoman, played
outstandingly by Michelle Pfeiffer.
"Meow."
It also happens to feature Michael Keaton
returning to his role as Batman, and Danny
DeVito as a hideous version of the Penguin,
in a part written specifically for him.
With Pfeiffer in the catsuit, Tim Burton at
the height of his directorial powers, and
Keaton's willingness to let his smug yet charming
Bruce Wayne share the spotlight with two formidable
foes, this sequel earned praise from critics
and became a box office hit.
"The liberation of Gotham has begun."
In 2019, the DC Extended Universe saw Ben
Affleck hang up the Bat-cape, and Henry Cavill's
Superman was still up in the air.
Even the runaway success of Aquaman couldn't
seem to save Warner Bros.' superhero franchise.
That's when Shazam! arrived to electrify audiences.
Shazam! tells the tale of Billy Batson, a
kid who's granted Superman-like superpowers,
and the ability to transform into an adult,
by an aging wizard.
The result is a movie that strips away all
the DC darkness and gives us a film that's
both sweet and fun.
It's also a movie about the importance of
family and finding your place in the world,
which is a lot nicer than watching the Caped
Crusader murdering people.
On top of all that, Shazam! has the right
amount of weirdness to make it stand out from
the superhero pack.
It isn't afraid to embrace its oddball comic
book origins, and the result is an absolute
blast.
And ultimately, that's kind of the point of
the film: It's really fun to be a superhero.
Guardians of the Galaxy earns its spot by
being a galactic joy to behold, bringing '70s
arena rock and Marvel superheroes to outer
space.
Zoe Saldana enchants as the green-skinned
Gamora; Bradley Cooper shows his impressive
range as the voice of Rocket Raccoon, and
Vin Diesel's Groot makes three words speak
volumes.
Plus, Dave Bautista's Drax the Destroyer steals
every scene.
"Nothing goes over my head.
My reflexes are too fast.
I would catch it."
Before Guardians, the Marvel Cinematic Universe
had been pretty straightforward.
Sure, there were fire-breathing dudes, and
dark elves, but this was a movie about a talking
tree, a smart-aleck raccoon, and a whistling
space pirate.
Writer-director James Gunn pulled it off,
injecting those losers and scoundrels with
wit and warmth.
We are all Groot.
In 1995, Sylvester Stallone tried bringing
Judge Dredd to the silver screen, and the
result was an absolute disaster.
"You started a massacre!"
"I caused a revolution!"
"You betrayed the law!"
"LAAAAAAAAWWWW!!!"
Fortunately, the mean-mugging lawman got a
second shot in 2012, when Karl Urban donned
the grungy red helmet.
The plot of Dredd is incredibly simple: the
world is a dystopian nightmare, and Mega-City
One is crawling with crime, and Dredd and
his psychic partner have to clear out floor
after floor of a skyscraper to bring down
a powerful crime lord.
The violence here is surprisingly beautiful,
with slow motion and vivid colors used to
incredible effect.
If graceful, gory violence is your thing,
then Dredd is required viewing.
Often described as Avengers 2.5, Civil War
featured tons of Avengers, and told a politically
charged story that set Earth's Mightiest Heroes
against one another in an eye-popping big-screen
battle royale.
Along with giving fans high-stakes heroes
vs. heroes battles, Civil War also introduced
Black Panther to mainstream audiences and
took a major step toward moving the MCU forward
by picking over some of the fallout from Age
of Ultron.
But even if you're not up on all the Marvel
lore, it's still one heck of a fun thrill
ride.
More explosive, more affecting, and funnier
than the first, Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2 is another snarky space epic powered by
a soulful classic rock soundtrack and awesome
visuals.
This time around, the Guardians square off
against Ayesha, high priestess of The Sovereign,
and eventually the godlike Ego.
Memorable performances from Pom Klementieff,
Karen Gillan, Michael Rooker, Sylvester Stallone
and Kurt Russell also make this sequel a must-see.
Critics who quibbled with Vol. 2's hyperactive
style and emotional moments missed one of
the funniest movies in Marvel's collection.
Until 2017, Thor was little more than a pompous
prince who liked hitting things with a hammer
and took himself way too seriously.
Marvel just needed the right filmmaker to
turn this Asgardian into a likable guy, and
they found it with Taika Waititi, who scaled
back the Shakespearean theatrics and turned
Thor into a well-meaning goofball.
"I choose to run toward my problems.
And not away from them."
Paired with a nebbishy Bruce Banner, Ragnarok
becomes an Odd Couple comedy in space, and
the funniest film in the MCU.
Add an '80s aesthetic, the super-cool score,
Thor battling Hulk in a gladiator match, and
a cast that includes Jeff Goldblum at his
strangest, and all the problems out of the
Thor franchise are perfectly hammered out.
The Winter Soldier is much more than just
a superhero movie, it's Marvel getting political.
Winter Soldier finds a recently-thawed Steve
Rogers in a world where things aren't quite
black and white anymore.
It's hard to know who to trust, and Cap quickly
finds himself in the middle of a conspiracy
that involves secret Hydra agents, metal-armed
assassins, and, worst of all, an evil Robert
Redford.
With the fate of the world hanging in the
balance, Cap goes rogue.
Winter Soldier features some of the most suspenseful
scenes you'll ever see in a superhero film,
with tense moments that boil over into fantastic
action scenes.
The film also shakes up the MCU, setting up
the stakes for Civil War.
Winter Soldier is a masterclass in action
and tension, and the best entry in the Captain
America franchise.
Though the big-screen Superman is dark and
dreary these days, he got his start as a brilliant
red-and-blue beacon of hope.
Richard Donner's 1978 Superman starring Christopher
Reeve was an instant classic, pulling in an
A-list cast and telling a classic story complete
with a dastardly Lex Luthor.
From the cutting-edge special effects to the
casting of then-unknown Reeve as Clark Kent,
Superman set the template for the modern-day
superhero movies, proving you could take these
characters seriously and still have a whole
lot of fun in the process.
M. Night Shyamalan's Unbreakable was a brilliant
exploration and deconstruction of comic book
characters at a time when superhero movies
weren't the juggernauts of Hollywood they'd
soon become, and a radical departure from
the superhero films that had come before.
Unbreakable treated superheroes seriously,
laying the groundwork for many comic book
movies to come.
Plus, the movie is just good; Bruce Willis
and Samuel L. Jackson give outstanding performances,
the score is incredibly haunting, and the
film created a universe where James McAvoy
would someday unleash his inner beast.
Change was overdue in the MCU when Black Panther
pounced onto the scene.
Played by Chadwick Boseman, T'Challa first
showed up in Civil War and quickly became
a fan favorite.
The courageous cat made his triumphant return
in 2018, and when his film hit theaters, audiences
fell in love with Wakanda.
"This never gets old."
Black Panther is one of the highest-grossing
films of all time, and the first superhero
movie to get an Oscar nomination for Best
Picture.
Talented actors like Lupita Nyong'o, Daniel
Kaluuya, and Angela Bassett struck a chord
with audiences, and the African setting allowed
filmmaker Ryan Coogler to explore a rich culture
that's little-seen in Hollywood films.
The film also introduced one of the greatest
bad guys in superhero history: Erik Killmonger.
Played to villainous perfection by Michael
B. Jordan, Killmonger is a stone-cold, but
sympathetic, murderer.
With its fantastic characters and beautiful
world-building, it's no wonder Black Panther
was a breakthrough hit.
The superhero movie genre is mostly dominated
by dudes, but the gender roles were finally
reversed in 2017 when the most iconic female
hero finally got her own movie.
Wonder Woman was a critical success and a
box office smash, reinvigorating DC's superhero
universe and giving kids a different kind
of hero to look up to.
In a DC franchise that had up until then been
defined by grit and gloom, this Amazon princess
emerged as a beacon of courage and hope.
She isn't punching down cities or branding
bad guys.
She's a protector of the people trying to
end all war.
Unlike the DCEU's Batman or Superman, Diana
actually cares about people and sees the good
in humanity.
She's more concerned with saving lives than
serving justice.
Superman's symbol might stand for "hope,"
but it's Wonder Woman that restored our faith
in the power of superheroes.
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse takes the
iconic wall-crawler's web-slinging mythos
in exciting new directions by introducing
audiences to a vibrant world of parallel dimensions,
parallel lives, and talking cartoon pigs.
"You got a problem with cartoons?"
The plot follows teenage Miles Morales who's
bitten by, you guessed it, a radioactive spider.
But things get even more complicated when
a powerful machine opens up portals to other
worlds, blasting a whole team's worth of alternate
universe Spider-People into Miles' New York
City.
The film's brilliant animation captures the
feeling of reading the comic book like few
movies have before it.
It couples the visuals with a daring story
that takes a daunting multiverse concept and
roots it in character moments that any viewer
can relate to, young or old.
Most superhero movies are about special people
doing the impossible, Into the Spider-Verse
is a rare gem that makes you feel like you
can do the impossible too.
2017's Logan finally allowed Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine the R-rated chance to slice and
dice his foes like Marvel's own Freddy Kreuger.
But the movie is so much more than just an
extra-bloody X-Men adventure.
It's an ode to a hero at the end of his life,
and a somber meditation on violence, regret,
and redemption.
Inspired by classic Westerns and the Old Man
Logan comic books, Logan stands apart from
the rest of the X-Men series.
It takes the nearly-unkillable Wolverine and
brings him back down to earth as a broken,
forlorn mortal man.
Jackman and co-star Patrick Stewart give some
of the best performances of their careers
with stark portrayals of their characters
as dying men in a defeated world.
Their last mission is to protect Laura, a
young clone of Wolverine's who still has hope
for the future.
The three leads' surprisingly familial connection
makes for a grounded and emotional story that
resonates in a way few superhero movies can
match.
"Bad s--- happens to people I care about.
Do you understand me?"
"Then I'll be fine."
2004's The Incredibles is still one of the
best superhero movies, and one of the best
Pixar movies too.
It's full of brilliant little moments that
stick in your memory, like the hilarious interviews
that open the film, or the macabre "no capes"
montage.
There's also the fact that this is a kids'
movie that deals seriously with adult themes;
characters go through midlife crises, and
grapple with hiding their identities in a
world that won't accept them.
The action sequences are fluid and fun, just
as thrilling as almost anything you'll see
in a live-action Marvel or DC film.
But what really elevates the movie is the
family at the center of the story, who are
charming both at home and on the battlefield.
They're also completely believable as a family
unit.
"Both of you will get a grip or so help me
I will ground you for a month.
Understand?!"
After 11 years and 21 films, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe brought the Infinity Saga to a close
with Endgame, an epic action flick that smashed
box office records and said farewell to some
of our most beloved superheroes.
Despite running three hours long, it never
feels its length, with each act feeling wildly
different from the last.
It all leads up to the most ambitious superhero
battle ever filmed, featuring dozens of characters
from across the MCU in a climactic battle
for the fate of the universe.
Though it starts off with a tone of mourning,
Endgame ends up feeling like an absolute joy.
Its biggest achievement is that it truly works
as the finale to a decade-plus of storytelling.
Watching all of Marvel's characters reunite
one last time is stirring, and while the MCU
will likely continue long past the original
six Avengers, Endgame provides the perfect
conclusion to their story as a team.
The granddaddy of the MCU, Iron Man is just
as good today as it was in 2008.
With heavy hitters like the X-Men and Spider-Man
already sold off to larger studios, Marvel
had to pull heroes from the bench to launch
its shared universe.
Iron Man was one of the best of the rest,
so director Jon Favreau was given a lot of
freedom, and the studio banked on the charisma
of Robert Downey, Jr.
The gamble worked, and this movie managed
to tell an extremely fun story while setting
the tone for a massive $20 billion franchise
to follow.
It's also a textbook example of how to get
a superhero origin story right.
"I am Iron Man."
Over the course of ten years and 18 films,
Marvel had been preparing for the most ambitious
crossover event in movie history, and when
it came time for the world's mightiest heroes
to fight the universe's biggest bad guy, the
results were better than anyone could've dreamed.
2018's Infinity War quickly became one of
the highest-grossing films of all time, integrating
countless characters into a cohesive world.
Most importantly, Infinity War totally delivered
when it came to the Mad Titan, who Marvel
fans had been eagerly awaiting since 2012.
In a surprising twist, Marvel even made Thanos
the film's true protagonist.
And then, the Mad Titan wins the day in one
of the gutsiest endings in blockbuster history.
Watching so many beloved characters turn to
dust is absolutely heartbreaking, but it also
set the stage for the climactic finale to
Hollywood's most successful franchise.
"I am Groot!"
"I am Steve Rogers!"
The pinnacle of the MCU was established relatively
early on, with the first ever team-up of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes in The Avengers, written
and directed by fan favorite Joss Whedon.
The result proved an unqualified critical
and commercial hit.
"A new universe!"
It's one of the most successful films ever
made, pulling in more than $1.5 billion worldwide,
and it scored some of the best reviews earned
by any of the year's wide releases.
It's a comic book brought to life in the best
possible way, and Whedon managed to blend
a bevy of characters, geek-out fan service,
and a compelling story into one perfect package.
The superhero movie genre was in its infancy
in 2004, but despite being practically ancient,
Spider-Man 2 still holds up.
This is a movie that features an Evil Dead-style
horror sequence, a superhero showdown on a
train, the most heartbreaking date ever filmed,
and a villain who feels like an old-timey
Universal monster.
None of this should fit together, but it all
works perfectly.
"Spider-Man!
Spider-Man!
Does whatever a spider can!
Spins a web, any size…"
But Spider-Man 2 really shines by giving us
the most relatable superhero of all time.
Unlike the mega-rich Batman or the nearly-immortal
mutant Wolverine, Peter is just a normal guy,
trying to deliver pizza and woo the girl of
his dreams while keeping the streets of New
York safe.
When he's not fighting supervillains, he's
struggling with everyday problems.
Yeah, he can shoot webs and climb walls, but
this version of the wall-crawler is still
the most human superhero we've ever seen.
The Dark Knight isn't just the best superhero
movie ever made; it ushered in a new era for
comic book movies.
Suddenly, superhero movies could be high art,
worthy of awards and accolades, all thanks
to the Caped Crusader and the Clown Prince
of Crime.
Here was a film with one of the greatest opening
sequences of all time.
It explored heavy concepts like what people
will do when forced into terrible circumstances,
and told the tragic story of the rise and
fall of Harvey Dent.
It also featured the greatest 18-wheeler flip
of all time.
Heath Ledger won a posthumous Oscar for his
turn as the chaos-loving Joker, and all these
years later, people still shudder when they
remember his freaky scars and his terrifying
magic trick.
It's a performance for the ages, and thanks
to Ledger, the Joker joined the best cinematic
villains, alongside Darth Vader and Hannibal
Lecter.
With its impressive acting, pounding score,
impeccable direction, and intense action,
The Dark Knight is the kind of superhero movie
that fans deserve and need.
"I'm just ahead of the curve."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.